three three three three
カツオ武将結了と
香りが家中に広がる
一昔前まで鰹節削り器は一家に一台ありました
日本の風景
私がかつお節を削る姿に出会ったのは3年前の夏です
当時私はクラブやパーティーで遊ぶことに生きがいを感じていて
母親にちょっとおばあちゃんつに変えればと福岡へ帰ることをすすめられました
おばあちゃんは足が悪くて札はご飯を作ってくれる強度があまりなかったのですが
私の話を聞いていたのかお店からカツオ箱を取り出して
削って
お出汁を引いて a
お味噌汁を作ってくれました
鰹節削りを一言で表現すると
愛だと思っています
この鰹節は海の恵み
そしてこの鰹節削り器は
山の恵み
自然の恵みがたくさんの愛を与えてくれます
昔々戦国武士たちは
これを持っていれば戦に勝てるかつ男の星だと
足に忍ばせてお守り代わりにしていました
時にはこれをしゃぶって栄養をとっていたそうです
自分への愛
私はかつお節が好きですぎてたまらなくて
鰹節を伝えたい一心で
鰹節のイメージを変えたいと銀座のクラブで削っていたことがあります
そのずキュアのカツオターシーという肩書であのまあお客さんの隣に座るときに削り器
と一緒に座らせてもらっていました
結構を替えるときは絶対に後ろを振り向かないという銀座の男たちが
鰹節削りを目の前にした時に
無邪気になってちょっと削り方上手いですね
ちょっとちょっと私にも削らせてください自然とそういう会話が飛び交っていました
心と心を繋ぐ愛
そしておばあちゃんが私に削ってくれた時のことを今でも鮮明に覚えています
ちょっと腰が曲がっていて
手は大きくてしっかり勝つを武将に切ってー
ギコ違いけれど
とてもとても優しいリズムで温かい香り
それで作ってくれたお味噌汁は世界で一番美味しかったです
大切な人を思うわい
鰹節削りは
愛をたくさん作ってくれます
皆さんも一緒に鰹節を削ってみませんか
最後にもう一度ケツ出せてください
今の削りはこうしてここに立ってスピーチをできるのはたくさんの方のご協力のおかげ
です
感謝を込めてありがとうの愛を伝えたいと思いますありがとうございました